menteur non je mens pas je te jure que
je t'aime enfin compte est toujours un
tout petit peu mais je suis producteur
c'est mon boulot et je te rembourserai
je te promets que je te rembourserai je
te donne 72 heures après ça j'étais trop
[Musique]
content pour un con je crois que t'as
pas dresser un portrait tout à fait
juste de notre investisseur à va à
chaque fois qu'on l'a été dans la mer
drom on m'a trouvé les solutions tout le
monde ne parle que de ça il faut du fric
vous avez qu à venir sur le plateau
franck pierce sera là excusez moi
monsieur pierce pardon vous interromps
j'ai peur
ils étaient assurés à hauteur de 5
millions de dollars temps x ray de tron
pas le seul plan du film et ils
empochent 5 millions de dollars vraiment
aurait vécu tout ce qui serait resté
c'est l'indemnité de la science
j'ai organisé une entourloupe commence à
nantes au lot on prépare tout comme si
on avait vraiment l'intention de faire
un film qui on prend une grosse
assurance pour la star qui fera sa
casquette vous êtes duke montano ici du
montana qu'est ce que vous faites je
continue ma petite séance de roulette
russe quotidienne vous êtes parfait pour
ce personnage en particulier
je me suis tout de suite attaché à cette
histoire renault va et c'est un bon
vieux western à l'ancienne un kingdom
quoi
félicitations
occupants dans une cascade il rêve et là
on est riche on est riche
you montana s'il était encore en vie je
sais très bien que tu poyet ou ce [ __ ]
de canassons zouk mais c'est génial vous
êtes vivant
n'est pas ce cas là on dirait qu'il a
deux filles ça n'a rien de sorcier de
tuer quelqu'un bon dieu on va tourner et
l'incroyable scène du pont cordes qui en
a qui vont pas en revenir sans vous
serez six pieds sous terre avec mes
bottes
je te connais autres
l'équipe donnerait sa vie pour trait pas
les mots que j'aurai choisi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais enfin quelles sortes d'êtres
humains est ce que tu es je suis
producteur
pour réaliser un film à un million de
dollars est bon ou les ans une pet âgées
suis pas adepte des signes ostentatoires
d'opulence êtes con qua non
il n'y a pas de plus grand fléau qui
ravage les états unis de l'intérieur le
président lui-même prend la crise des
opioïdes très au sérieux
leur jeune a été arrêté à la frontière
qui leur passeur
pour ça il a travaillé sous couverture
pendant un an c'est peut-être dangereux
de pousser nos ventes là ouais mais je
vois pas quel au choix
notre produit sera le véritable tout
preniez antidouleur non addictif
qu'est ce que c'est que ça étant associé
à la diction salut dans le cerveau et
aujourd'hui elle même
je cherche mon garçon étiez vous au
courant de quelques problèmes avec votre
fils comme quoi
quand appuyant sur des résultats tu veux
que leur médicament d'un milliard de
dollars soit retiré du marché ça
pourrait coûter beaucoup plus que ton
travail de prof faut que tu un plan
plein pour dire la vérité
fais attention
est ce que ceux ci drik et le genre à
dévoiler des noms lorsque ce serait
déplaisant pour tout le monde
[Musique]
ils vont vous attaquer mais ce que vous
faites là pour être la chose la plus
important de votre vie
on vise à transporter la drogue pour toi
puis le tabac c'est la plus grosse crise
de santé publique ok ce n'est pas notre
responsabilité celle de qui
tu peux pas aller là-bas tout seul on
peut pas lâcher on peut faire ça
vous croyez qu'on est là pour faire quoi
faire une différence
on peut se retrouver n'importe où dans
le monde
on n'a plus beaucoup de temps dernière
chose
[Musique]
mi temps c'est quoi ça
d'ailleurs si tu veux tout savoir je
conte la livraison de missiles sam et
connaît on dirait ma soeur je suis
content avec ce courage
ce qui m'incombe de confinement ses
comptes
mais
on y va à fond on fait la totale
d'un coup respectueux gestes barrières
latour désolé alors bon rétablissement à
mon virus sable
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes
l'heure est grave
la france
elle est au bord du gouffre
non ces circonstances exceptionnelles
j'ai la grande joie de vous annoncer mon
retour
au cinéma
votre retour au cinéma mais voilà c'est
pas le concordat petit black françois
trinh-duc aussi votre retour au cinéma
dans un film souffre et n'entendent
nouvelle je vous entends je souffre mais
je dis tu le sais votre retour
généralement je fais ce que je dis
mais vous n'êtes pas mon professeur je
suis pas neutre il est vrai pas à me
dire qui je suis qui je ne me fait pas
vivre les 10 est à mon sens inné c'est
un mensonge une sélection à lomé
kalemie nateur
si vous voulez
savez pour être président faut être
calme
bon
[Musique]
post 1
coralie qui postent arino en
[Musique]
fait les
frais
[Musique]
des cadeaux
m
james m
[Musique]
des groupes
du beurre ailleurs du beurre
pour faire bien bertrand faire savoir si
vous avez deux minutes le duc aimerait
faire son commentaire
[Musique]
manceron vos cuisses on était parfaite
comment appelez-vous ces petits
chaussons le délicieux truffe et pommes
de terre c'est bon pour les cochons
excusez
mon saut
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'elle était cuisinier tu
peux pas renoncer et enfermé ici alors
qu'à tant de choses à vivre
je m'appelle louise j'aimerais devenir
votre apprenti qui trop vieux pour faire
on apprend dessus s'est plaint d'une
colline et prenez moi je suis sûr qu'il
reviendra
c'est un bon quand vous allez là si vous
donnez un peu de mal les diligences
s'arrêteront ici avant la fin de
l'automne
il faut partager cet endroit avec tout
le monde
nos robes le bourgeois ou paysage
nous aurons besoin de tout l'espace pour
une grande chambre à manger inventé un
lieu de gourmandise un lieu de bouche
d'ailleurs je dois reconnaître que vous
êtes en train de vous sert jolie
réputation par le vote robert jusqu'au
château si tous les clients sans duc et
tous les clients sont rois
le quart visage de vous rendre une
visite d'appétit
important c'est que vous n'avez plus
besoin du coup de chance
voulais être libre de créer de nouvelles
recettes folie tu oublies chamfort et
ses semblables et tu leur doit rien le
monde est en train de changer
je suis pas d'avoir envie de manger il
faut savoir manger c'est un art est vrai
que jean n'est pas fait pour le commun
des mortels
j'exige que vous fermez votre gueule que
c'est le peuple un jour il s'asseoir à
la table et ce jour-là chamfort et ses
semblables finiront pendus à des
potences
je voudrais pas trop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut dan survenu quand exactement
aujourd'hui quand est ce que je pourrais
voir isabelle elle se souvient pas toi
jusqu'ici la ti c'est ce que je voudrais
bien le dire
morales explique sam afin de sang
tu sais que chaque jour elle m'a demandé
au tt
non des mois elle m'a regardé comme si
j'étais pas la bonne personne
[Musique]
ce qui était une bonne mère j'me sens
salut ma chérie j'apportais si si c'est
pour moi pourquoi tu laisses notre fille
appelée cette femme maman mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fout ici va-t-on marinara tekki
pourquoi est ce que t il justifie la
rahma élève sa fille et moi sa mère
vraiment
[Musique]
je ne comprenais pas ce moment là et tu
comprends toujours pas mais il fallait
que je parle pour halimi pour pouvoir
ensuite revenir et faire partie de cette
famille la bonne manière si vous voulez
encore debout
et fier de chance
et pourquoi ça parce que tu as toi
et
avec vous
bon
julian
[Musique]
chandler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la collecte
at il dit
tu connais
[Musique]
pour un cercle ma famille